A wise man once said,...
..."A glass of milk a day will make you healthy, wealthy and wise."
Well, what about sending secret messages with it?
Can we do that too?
Now, this is an incredibly easy trick to do.
All you need to do is pour a glass of milk...
...and then get a Q-Tip out.
Draw your message out with a Q-Tip...
...and then let it dry for at least 30 minutes.
If you have a heat lamp or something, it might be fine but...
...you know, whatever.
When you're done, your paper should look normal.
And once it looks like this, you're ready to go.
Let's reveal the message.
Take an iron and slowly go over the paper.
What's gonna happen is that the fat in the milk is going to brown up...
...as opposed to burn.
And it will reveal the message that was stained into the paper itself.
A pretty nifty and easy trick for you to try at home.
So, that concludes season one of Scientific Tuesdays.
If you enjoyed Scientific Tuesdays, make sure you check back in a couple of weeks...
...when we start season two.
You're gonna love it.
I assure you.
See you then.